i'm gonna be careful and not put this
one up on the screen just because
there's some things in here i gotta skip
over he wanted me to leave out because
he's a doctor and
uh promised bullet points not use my
name specialty of medicine and city okay
so
um he wants me to call him a
neurosurgeon
in atlanta he has 60 pages of court
documents
let me just summarize what he sent over
here he meets his ex-wife
in medical school he had just turned 22
graduated from harvard she was the first
girlfriend
i'm assuming this is you know who he
lost his virginity to and maybe the same
for her we don't know
there were a lot of red flags she
clearly had borderline personality
disorder
daddy issues her dad went to a federal
prison for four years while she was in
college
for bank fraud she was also a
pathological liar
you guys will start to notice that the
apple doesn't typically fall
very far from the tree if there's
problems in the parental units
and she grew up in that household that's
that was the
bar to which she set her life to right
i think they say that most of children's
development is usually done
by the about the age of seven or eight
or nine i think somewhere
around that anyway so dude goes to
federal prison bank pathologic liars
somehow due to my own internal
deficiencies
now this is a smart guy he went to
medical school he's a neurosurgeon right
even though his spidey senses picked up
on this he continues to accept her
excuses for the various lies that she
told
she insisted that we have sex for the
first time when i was 22 a month after
we met her and then demanded that we get
married right away since i took her
virginity
she told me that she was a virgin when
we met and it turned out that she had
actually been with four other guys
before i met her
i found this out right before the
wedding i would have called off the
wedding right at that point
again if you have options if you've spun
plates and you've contrasted and you've
seen the good from the bad then you have
the ability to make those choices
his spidey senses said something to him
before the wedding
when he learned about the information
but he proceeded anyway
her excuse was that she had been raped
and went into a downward spiral
i want to sneeze and say a [ __ ] but
i don't have a sneeze coming but you get
the idea
uh four other guys daniel spiral it was
basically pretty woman like the movie
syndrome
i wanted to fix her and tend her
physiological
emotional and material needs captain
sabaho is what we call that
we had two sons together now 21 and 19.
shortly after the birth of our first son
she became ultra abusive hmm
abuse big red flag had he dated her a
little bit longer so
one of the other things that i learned
which i picked up from sean is tactical
guide to women is a great book
and i talked about it in my book is
before you do anything like march into a
slaughterhouse of marriage
date for at least a year and a half two
years so you can see what she's made of
he bangs her a month after he meets her
and then she insists on getting married
right after that so he's basically known
her for two months
you don't get to know somebody in two
months you're dating the actor you're
dating the representative
anyway two sons uh she becomes abusive
he would have seen that likely if he
dated her for at least a year and a half
two years
before anything she got her first job at
john's hoskins
as a dermatologist and since i was still
a resident training began to belittle me
and use her status as the breadwinner
for the family
for three years to bully me into beta
status
we moved and i became the breadwinner as
a
neurosurgeon but the abuse never stopped
i could fill a podcast with hours of
examples of her absolutely
traditional cultural background despite
all of this i maintain a great
relationship see
traditional cultural background is
usually what guys usually shop for
and you think after two months of dating
that you've got enough frame around it
no year and a half two years minimum see
what she's made out of
despite all of this i maintain a great
relationship with my sons after about 10
more years
couldn't handle anymore and made plans
at least mentally to exit quietly
divorce her and move on
in mid 2013 i was looking for disneyland
tickets for my kids
on the family home computer and found
that she left her email open
here we go i found a file with a
treasure trove of pornographic videos
she had made with another guy i was
floored
she was always passing herself off as
being religious and pious and constantly
judgmental of how other women or girls
that my kids went to school with had
skirts that were too short
and yet she's making porn with other
dudes while she's married to this man
and abusing him and he's a neurosurgeon
i tried to divorce her but she kept
threatening to kill herself
most guys would have just walked away
and let her right i stayed for another
18 months
18 months he signed up for another 18
months of torture
moved into an apartment before moving
back to the house when she claimed an
overdose on benzos
and we worked out a post-natural
agreement given her the six million
dollar mortgage-free house
for another decade while i paid half the
cost
primary physical custody of the kids she
she got the kids
and another million to get the kids
through high school
i was supposed to see the kids nights
and weekends as there were schedules
allowed i filed for divorce in 2015 when
i realized that she was still having an
affair
the details are unimportant unimportant
but i filed and moved out of the house
into a small apartment
having given virtually everything i had
away to this animal
by now he's calling her an animal
she immediately began lying to the kids
about why dad moved out of the house
what was i talking about earlier
parental alienation where the mother
makes up this horseshit about what a
terrible man the father is
which is almost entirely always crap
i became despondent and nearly hopeless
until mutual family and friends
approached me and told me that my
ex-wife
had told them one of the one of them was
a female ob
gyn and she told me that she would help
me see my sons if i showed her proof of
the video
i reluctantly gave her a copy and fast
forward to a little
and fast forward a little to family law
deposition where my ex-wife alleged
that i had physically assaulted her
excuse me
that i had physically assaulted our 16
year old at tennis camp
it was a complete lie i admitted to the
distribution of the v
of the video to this female doctor my
wife
filled criminal revenge board charges
against me
and used the threat of criminal trial to
settle demands for 6.5 million dollars
6.5 million dollars
that's a lot of money i refused and
ultimately went to
keep in mind she's banging other dudes
on the side making porn
and leaving it on the computer while
this dude's trying to book disneyland
tickets and she wants six and a half
million dollars
and the house i refuse and ultimately
went to trial
where she stated these outrageous lies
that i'd use the video to coerce her
into a one-sided divorce agreement oh
shocking now she's making up stuff
i was convinced based on these lies but
it was but it was ultimately expunged as
the legal system and the da's office
became aware of her efforts
to extort me and her perjury in the
matter
they did nothing despite ample evidence
and sworn statements
i'm telling you guys women get away with
so much in family law
we're almost done here the assistant d.a
called me and told me in this climate of
me too
in the state that he lived in it would
be difficult to get a perjury conviction
this is a very liberal state by the way
it would be difficult to get a perjury
conviction
on uh of her or her attorney and had
extensively discussed
internally in the da's office she was a
sidebearer here's where
my ex-wife was in charge of cash
receipts
for my practice and stole eight hundred
thousand dollars in
cash over eight years this
[ __ ] stole 800 000 from his business
made porn with some other dude when he's
buying disneyland tickets for the family
wants six and a half million dollars in
a settlement and a six million dollar
home and stole 800 grand from this dude
from his practice over eight years
oh hang on it gets worse and spent
hundreds of thousands of the corporate
credit card on her purse's shoes
personal travel to see her boyfriend
first class international airline
tickets for her parents
while we were married i'm sure she kept
a good bit of the cash in a safe
somewhere without my knowledge
dudes if you're going through a divorce
and you have a terrible boating accident
and you lose your nano ledger and all
your cryptocurrency
don't feel bad i'm telling you right now
it's okay
i've seen a lot of this far worse than
what could ever happen
anyway she kept copies christian use
attorney general went through federal
grand subpoena blah blah blah
eight years comparing to computer
records
more [ __ ] blah blah blah never
charged me did amend my tax returns
he spent three million dollars on
attorney fees
over five years of the divorce there is
no limit to the extent to which
a crazy woman will try everything to her
disposal to ruin a good man i'm going to
say that again
there is no limit to the extent to which
a crazy woman will try
everything at her disposal to ruin a
good man
doesn't matter how good of a guy you you
are doesn't matter if you're a stand-up
dude
any woman not all but any woman can
destroy a man in family court not all
will do it but any woman can you have to
understand that
there are a few take away here a man
should never marry before the age of 33
every man should be aware of borderline
personality disorder you should never
stay in a marriage with a crazy woman
for the kids
every man should have a prenup no matter
what they get married blah blah blah
okay that's it i mean
i don't want to go on banging on that
one it's but you get to the
you know like you get the point that's
just
one example of the millions of divorces
that happen every year in north america
and yet every single day some dummy
wants to go march into the
slaughterhouse that could completely
derail him
in a direction that ain't gonna be good
you